can we start by having you show the
process of preparing your body for an
interview
sure of I can do it right now as a
matter of fact the first thing that I
would think about is
just to become aware of myself
from my head all the way down into my
sits bones and I might move my legs a
little bit so I can feel my joins and
then get a little bit more forward
so I can feel my feet so I can be
grounded and then what I would do is I
would check my head neck relationship
right here and what I may do is just
gently look down to the floor and then
very gently free my neck to look up a
little bit
so I can feel that relationship with my
head and my spine and then I might just
bring my whole body forward like this
and then back
it reminds me being on a horse
so when a horseback Riders are perfect
students of the Alexander technique in
fact Alexander was a horseback rider
so now I might put my hands like this to
the side of my rib cage and do something
called the whispered ah
it's a way of calming my breath
and calming my nervous system
and then what I may do is instead of
letting a whisper to ah I may just do
some Counting
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
and then what I might do is two of sets
of tens on one breath
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
so that gets me going my breathing
mechanism
and I am aware this is something that
would be great to do it just before you
go on set
so many of the actors that I work with
they might do something like that I have
this is a quick warm-up I have for
example in the book that I've written I
have many different warm-ups
leaning forward
and that is not just the head leaning
forward with the neck it's the entire
body the entire body so you might have
noticed that when I leaned forward I was
continuing to lengthen my spine
and this is something that animals might
do they may just lean a little bit
forward getting ready to attack
or their their Lean Forward because
they're interested
so they they are they're they're like
pointing
um dogs do that beautifully right you
know they lean forward and maybe one paw
goes out
and what they're doing is they're just
looking
or they're listening
or feeling the moment
you know it has something to do with
that
you had said something about it's a
perfect exercise for an actor just
before they go on set
if they don't if an actor does not have
let's say their own room
how would they find a space in the chaos
of preparing I love this uh yes actors
will find a little corner
in the movie studio set away from the
action so they can do some of this thing
and luckily uh the crew is usually used
to seeing actors do very odd things to
prepare
you know you sometimes hear well so and
so they were very standoffish and they
never mingled with the the crew or the
other cast I always feel like maybe they
needed their own time to prepare
absolutely uh every actor has their own
way of preparing and they may do
different things uh Alexander will help
them to release a lot of tension
and to connect them to the breath
and hopefully with uh the character's
intention
so and then there is that and I will
speak on that in terms of how does the
character come to life how do you embody
with your whole being
the character
is this a routine you do every day yeah
well it is a way of living this is the
thing about Alexander that is quite
different from so many other methods
you use it in the act of life
it blew my mind when I first heard this
I said
that makes sense if you really want to
change the manner that you use yourself
how you use your breath how you move how
you stand how you sit or how you work
with computers or the um how you handle
a camera right you begin to integrate it
into your everyday life of course you
can think about it all the time you
would probably end up in a mental
institution but there is something about
it becoming real
in your life so then when you are in
front of a camera it's not so hard to
access it you see or if you're on stage
in front of thousands of people it's a
lot easier to integrate it and connect
with it
the other methods I watched for the
Alexander technique were lying on the
ground with the books and then the knees
to the sky which I tried before the
interview and it was wonderful oh good I
wasn't sure if I was using the right
amount of books so I tried different
ones is that something you also try on a
daily basis yeah I do that I do that
it's called a semi supine or a
constructive rest that's what I call it
or some people call it active rest
it is a way for you to ease yourself
and use gravity as a way of allowing all
your bones especially the spine to ease
into the floor
and to become aware so you learn that
awareness or living in your body it's a
very Lively event it's not it's not
closing your eyes and getting really
serious not at all it's not it's not
like a hypnotizing yourself into it but
it is a
an illumination of how you feel I like I
like to call it illumination because it
feels clearer
in terms of where your spine is between
your head and your spine and the legs
and the arms
and we have such a thing called
directions that we use to direct our
bodies while we're lying down
I heard one woman say she just felt
lighter like she she used to be a dancer
and she said as she got older she didn't
feel like she was moving correctly she
just felt lighter in her life everything
that she was doing so there there is
that there is that I actually I wanted
to appeal to my um
to here what what gets us down our
habits
the habits of our everyday life you know
try just the idea of trying to get it
right
or trying to do something well will
tense the neck automatically and will
compress your head back and down into
your spine so these are some of the
things that we are dealing with that are
very very habitual
and to me dealing with a habitual and
learning to shift it
consciously
is a very empowering
and where you go from there from the
habitual
you go then into the extraordinary
meaning that you're living outside of
the force of habit
and that's What actors that's where they
want to be because usually you know
scenes are especially important scenes
like turning points
our scenes where the character changes
and you do want to be free in doing that
so you're really telling the truth
and you're in the moment
and there's something that it's hard to
put your fingers on because it's the
thing about transformation
you know and it's going to be different
for everybody and everybody's going to
do it differently somehow
do you find some people uh are more
rigid than others where it is almost
impossible to get them to relax their
neck relax you know whether they had
military training whether they do you
know accounting work and they're just
behind a desk all day if someone usually
people come to me because they want to
change so they've come to a at a stage
in their lives that if they don't do it
if they don't change they realize that
they're going to be like that or Worse
the rest of their lives so they're very
clear about wanting to change right so
they're in a prime state right they want
to learn something different
in terms of rigid yeah yeah military
someone in the military might be a
little bit uh
um
reactive and uh fighting a little bit
but I've I've been surprised I've had
football players with necks like this
with muscle
and I will put my hands on them because
we do use our hands to help people
and somehow
they release their necks so much
and they have a very very uh heightened
experience
and it's emotionally very moving to see
someone like a football player
releasing completely their necks and
and breathing and getting a little bit
longer and lighter as you said and uh so
yeah it um or someone very old you know
that they're completely collapsed
that after a lesson there are they are
able to move very uh elegantly and
easily
you know and they haven't done that in
years
can you explain what collapsed means and
how I can show it to you I can show it
collapse has a lot to do with a lack of
consciousness
right so if I if I allow myself just to
go with gravity right now
I will become an old man really quick so
this is where I am and as I talk to you
I will talk to you like this and my
voice is getting a little bit in my
throat here
and I look quite old now and kind of
tired
and pretty soon you'll probably end this
interview
right but
if I can just release my neck and allow
my hair to regain a little bit of length
and to come forward from my hip joint
somehow I I become a bit younger
and more vibrant